a woman testified yesterday over on
capitol hill
about abortion in the united states and
the way abortion
used to be framed in the way old days of
i don't know 60 70 years ago is that
it's an evil evil act that no one would
even speak about
right that it's it's killing a baby it's
obviously a very evil act
then starting about i don't know 50
years ago or so
abortion began to be spoken of as some
kind of right but a tragic right you
know a right that people don't ever want
to use but we have but women need to
have that right this was largely because
of second wave feminism which said that
women need a man like a fish need a
bicycle and
that women and men are exactly the same
but you know they have this big
difference which is women
conceive and carry and give birth to
children and so this is a
real impediment if uh women and men want
to have the exact same relationship to
sex and want to be able to walk away
from casual sex so therefore women need
to have the right to kill their babies
that was that was the argument of the
second way feminists but but even as
recently as 2008 even a little bit later
you had presidential candidates hillary
clinton saying that abortion should be
safe and legal but it should be rare
because it's bad it's a really bad thing
and it's tragic and so it should be safe
and legal and rare now that framing has
gone too now abortion is being called
an act of love
sb-8 has not only caused a near-total
abortion ban in texas it has made it
extremely dangerous to be pregnant in
texas
where our maternal morbidity and
mortality rate is already unconscionably
high especially for black women and
pregnant people of color
texas deserves better
i know firsthand that abortion saves
lives for the thousands of people i've
cared for abortion is a blessing
abortion is an act of love abortion is
freedom
we need federal protection now we need
laws that elevate science and evidence
and recognize the dignity and autonomy
of people accessing care
abortion is
love
abortion is blessing abortion is freedom
war is peace freedom is slavery
ignorance
is strength
this
abortion is a sin and it's a very grave
sin
it's not an unforgivable sin but but it
is it is a it is a grave sin
and if you repent of it then
you're on you're getting on the right
track we'll get to that in just one
second first though something tells me
you look at some weird stuff on the
internet stuff that maybe you don't want
other people to know about stuff where
you close the blinds open up the
incognito window lean in real close and
type in
www.dailywire.com well
that information's out there unless
you're using a vpn such as my favorite
expressvpn it's a simple app for your
computer and your smartphone it encrypts
all your network data it tunnels it
through a secure vpn server so that your
isp cannot see any of your activity
think of how much of your life is on the
internet okay the people you message the
sites you've visited the videos you've
watched the things you buy they're all
being tracked by tech giants who can
sell your information for profit i do
not go online without having expressvpn
on my computer on my phone i just don't
do it it's so simple you forget about it
and you are protected make sure you go
check it out today okay stop handing
your personal data over to isps protect
yourself with the vpn i trust to keep my
privacy online expressvpn.com
michael head on over there get three
extra months free go to expressvpn.com
michael right now to learn more what
this woman is doing is
is worse
because she's not only defending
abortion
she is
blaspheming she is committing
real sacrilege a real heresy here
she is
inverting the moral order
calling it a great blessing an act of
love godly i mean that's what she's
saying it's a godly act right it's a
blessing where do blessings come from
they come from god abortion is love well
god god is love right that we hear this
in the scripture
she's she's equating abortion with
godliness with god himself that is some
really sick stuff
okay
it is probably
the inevitable consequence of a
political regime that tolerates abortion
is there's just this cognitive
dissonance right the safe legal and rare
thing you just can't hold it forever if
it's murder it shouldn't be legal if
it's if it's not murder if it's just
getting your appendix taken out then it
shouldn't be rare and so eventually that
tension is going to have to resolve
itself one way or the other and the way
the left has resolved it is that it's a
wonderful good thing and this comes from
the right actually has some
responsibility in this because the right
has adopted a lot of the liberal
language of maximizing individual
autonomy and about choice and you do you
and i'll do me and i would never impose
my views on you and you don't impose
your views on me which is preposterous
that's never existed that is not
possible in a self-government the whole
point of self-government is we persuade
one another of the way we view the world
and then we create laws in accordance
with that so
that was never going to work the right
largely seated the battlefield the left
took over
and now they call abortion a blessing
woe to those who call good evil and evil
good
but that that is the framing that we're
living under
she even snuck transgenderism in there
she said
that she's referring to women and
pregnant people of color that's even you
know even that ability to claim
victimhood very very important here
abortion saves lives
[Music]
the one thing first of all no woman
has any medical condition that is cured
by abortion
okay it's not that the there can there
are
there's really just one medical
condition an ectopic pregnancy where the
treatment of that condition will result
in the death of of the unborn baby and
even that is really the sort of double
effect it's not as though a doctor will
prescribe abortion and then that that's
th that is the cure it could be a double
effect though uh for the rest when you
hear about the risk to the health of the
life of the mother whatever it's just
completely made up it's just that does
not exist okay
so
that part is very silly but then of
course even even if there were something
to that
abortion does not save lives every
single abortion kills somebody
every single abortion results in death
but that's the upside down world we're
living in and because the left controls
the means of communication that's mostly
what people hear
because they control big tech because
they control the media because they
control
the institutions the universities that
is largely what people hear and that's
how they can be confused of that i'm so
glad you enjoyed that clip i would tell
you to watch the whole show on youtube
but youtube keeps censoring me for
stating perfectly plain facts they won't
let me even quote the director of the
cdc because they accuse me of engaging
in medical misinformation when i
directly quote the
the director of the cdc so make sure you
go get this show
uncensored uncut with all the facts over
at apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play all the places you get your
podcasts for free it's the michael
knowles show or of course subscribe to
dailywire.com
[Music]
[Music]
you